- Welcome to Antonio Heights.
Every week, it’s all about me!
- No cameras.
- Well, boys, looks like we’re stuck together forever
like stink on a skunk!
- Are all of us going to be here forever?
- WE’RE AMERICA’S TEAM NOW, #$%&@!
- NO!
Throw me, Daky!
- I don’t know...
- Here’s $150 million guarante—
WE’RE THE COOL TEAM.
REMEMBER THE '90s??!?!?!
- OK. Shake it off.
We’ll get 'em next year.
- There’s nothing I can do.
I mean, come on.
Who doesn’t love these guys?
- You know,
I’m ALSO a hot quarterback.
- Hey, never &%$#@^$ give up, kid.
- COME ON.
THEY’VE WON EIGHT GAMES IN THREE YEARS.
WE’RE AMERICA’S TEAM!
- OK, uh,
let’s earn it back.
I’M DAKOTA PRESCOTT,
AND I SWEAR I’M ALSO DANGEROUS.
But I’m also pretty safe, Mr. Jones.
- So I said,
‘What’s a whistle?’
I don’t need your fancy tech. I yell.
- WE’RE TAKING THAT BACK—
- NOPE!
- WHO’S BEING ROBBED NOW?
- WE DESERVE THIS—
- Think bigger, Tom.
- What about us?
- AWWWWWW.
- Thank you.
Now RESPECT—
- WE BEAT THE BROWNS.
TITANSMANIA!!!!!
- TITANS! TITANS! TITANS!
-I’m Football’s Tom Brady.
Please buy my special pliability roombas.
-Uh Tom, this is that subscribe thing for Bleacher Report.
-Why would *I* do that?
Can’t you get—
-Hi, I’m Julian Edelman, and I know Tom Brady.
Please subscribe to this channel.